طيب ينضم الينا من القاهره الفنان اليمني
حسين محب حسين صباح الخير وسعداء بلقائك
في صباح العربيه
[موسيقى]
صباح النور صباح الخير على جميع المحبين
والمتابعين لبرنامجكم صباح العربيه من هنا
نقول صباح الخير لكل العرب لكل المحبين
لهذا البرنامج الجميل وهذه القناه
الاكثر من رائعه اسر الله يحفظك احنا
اليوم راح نثقل عليك صحيناك بدري وراح
نخليك تغني وانت صاحي الصباح يعني اكثر
ملفتني هو يمكن
تغني في في الريف في الغرب بالتالي اليوم
هل وصلت الاغنيه
اليمنيه خليني اتكلم الى
اكثر خلنا نقول العالميه او على الاقل
اصبحت مالوفه في الوطن العربي
عشان ابي اطلب منك اغنيه بعدها صراحه
الاغنيه اليمنيه الان
وبالتحديد الصنعانيه اصبح لها صيت على على
مستوى واسع على النطاق العالم وهذا
شيء يسعدنا جدا واعتقد انه وسائل التواصل
الاجتماعي سهلت لنا هذا
الانتشار ومن زمان هي الاغنيه اليمنيه
بشكل عام الاغنيه اليمنيه هي لها مكانتها
الكبيره في شبه الجزيره العربيه وفي الوطن
العربي بشكل عام يعني حسين قبل ما يدركنا
الوقت حابين نسمع منك شيء قبل ما نتابع
الحديث يقولون يا حسين اذا اذا الحبيب راح
يشل العقل والقلب واشياء اخرى ايش راح
تغني
بصبح عليكم في صباح العربيه باغنيه صباحيه
غنيتها زمان لكن بنقول منها بيت كذا مقطوع
[موسيقى]
صدفته من صباح الله
وحييت وحياني مدلل ما اجمله محلاه
بنظراته تحداني
[موسيقى]
من صباح الله
وحييتوا وحيا بي مدلل ما اجمالي ما احلاك
بنظره
تحداني
سارح قلبي معاك
[موسيقى]
وفلت موضعه
ولا قدرت
امنعك امانه تجرح
امانه
فهموك حبيبي
واقنعوا
امانه
فهموه امانه فخم
[موسيقى]
بالله
الله الله امانه فهموه خلوه يقعد لانه اذا
اذا راح شل قلبي وعقلي معليش مو راضي تغني
لي اياها يا حسين لا وحافظ يعني
يمنياتك
اسمعي هذه
شو اللي قلبي يش
شل عقلي شل
شل روحي شل
شل قلبي شل عقلي شلي روحي
شال شلي قلبي شل عقلي شلي روحي شال
شلينا وما العين مني شله احلامي
شلي تفكيري وروش
اه شل افراحي امانه
قدنا
وقتلي شلي تفكيري اماني ما قدرت ما فعل
شلي قلبي شل
شل عقلي شل شل قلبي شلا
عقلي شلي روحي
شال شلي قلبي شل عقلي شلي روحي
هذه اغنيه جميله جدا يعني معنى ذلك لانه
عادل ذوقه حلو على عنجد طيب حسين بيعجاله
بدي اسالك هل تغيرت
اغنيه بنصرح بها انا صورتها كليب في في
لندن خلال زياره المؤخره قبل اسبوعين وان
شاء الله اول عرض بقى يكون عند الان لا
بلاش السؤال السؤال مش مهم لا لا لا راح
تعطينا منها مقطع نسمع
منها يا حسين
ان شاء الله اول عرض حيكون عندكم لا اول
عرض هذا تصوير لكن خلينا نسمع بس نقول ايش
هي
ايش هي اسمعها
[موسيقى]
بنقول تصريح معلن شفت من عذب فؤادي يوصل
لندن
بقول منها بطلع الدخله فقط يلا يلا المطلع
طبعا الكلمات والحان تفضل كلمات والحان
الشاعر المبدعه جمانه جمال نوجه لها تحيه
تصريحي
معلن
شفت من عذب فؤادي وسط لندن
[موسيقى]
ليتهن
ليس ذكرني او تذكر او تمس
[موسيقى]
كاك الله الله بس ما قلت لنا وين في وسطنا
اي شارع لا انت اكيد اكيد
ذكرتني حسين في في ايضا قصيده
المحضار ايضا كان في في ويلز وقال او في
لندن وقال ايضا قصيده
كمان ايش علاقه اليمنيين في لندن ما ادري
كل العرب شو علاقتهم بلندن مفضلين طب
خلينا ننهي اذا هيك بمقطع هيك صغير من
اغنيه من اختيارك ضايل معنا دقيقه واحنا
بنودعك وبنشكرك
عادل
[موسيقى]
يا ليالي يا ليالي
قالوا ان الحب حالي
ما سبب في ضيق حالي يا ليالي يا
[موسيقى]
ليالي عبريهم
اني قلبي
مرسيلهم
خبري الظالم بحالي
يا ليالي يا ليالي
بعد كل اللي حصل لي يا بشر روحي
عليلك
الاسى والهم حولي
والبوق في كل ليله
[موسيقى]
قالوا ان الحب حالي
يا ليالي يا ليالي
[موسيقى]
بعدي حصل لي يا بشر روحي علينا
الاسى والهم حولي
والبكاء في كل ليله لمتابعه المزيد من
الاخبار والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه
والوثائقيات والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا
الاشتراك في قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط
على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات